in the lead up to your Harley's in your
year leads right do any of your teachers
actually give you papers from past years
like 2013 okay has anyone ever asked for
okay all right now some some teachers
won't do it some some departments some
schools are doing that's fine that's
their policy okay but you owe it to
yourself to try and find some maybe if
your teacher won't do it that's okay
don't fight your friend he goes to
another school you buy and ask if you
can get there's there won't be that
different it might be a little bit but
you need to be able to practice them
beforehand and as much as possible
practice them under exam conditions what
does that mean yes sir
gets a no distraction have it under you
know 60 minutes 90 minutes whatever
don't have TV Facebook Instagram food
everywhere there right that's how I
normally study you don't do stuff like
that it's nice to have it there but it
won't prepare you for an actual
assessment okay if you're like me you go
into an example and you seriously swap
your normal brain which knows how to do
all this stuff and you swap it for an
exam brain which is under pressure and
it can't remember how to do things you
make really silly mistakes okay so to
avoid that do papers from the past
assess the same topics for the same
amount of time it's the best way to
practice okay